you're claiming that due to amber's
allegations of abuse you can't be in
pirate six
correct
um i'm saying that
after
everything had um
basically hit its media targets
and the hit pieces kept coming
it would be
i mean i would be a real simpleton to
not think that there was an effect on my
career based on ms heard's
words
whether they mention my name or not
you became aware prior to the
publication of this op-ed that you were
likely out for pirate six the disney was
considering dropping or dramatically
shrinking your role correct
no
can you pull up
uh defense exhibit 115 please mr deputy
do you see the the the date of this
article um beneath those bullet points
is
october 25th 2018. do you see that yes i
do and were you aware that as of october
25th 2018
about two months before this op-ed was
published
that it was being reported as it is in
this article that johnny depp is out as
jack sparrow in disney's pirates of the
caribbean film franchise as actor
battles financial issues and personal
dramas were you aware of that
i wasn't aware of that but it doesn't
surprise me given that two years had
gone by of
just constant
worldwide talk about me being this wife
peter
understood but you i'm sure that disney
was trying to
um
cut ties
to be safe the metoo movement was in
full swing at that point
right and to the extent they were trying
to cut ties to be safe that was as much
as two months prior to you publish or to
to misheard publishing the op-ed in the
washington post correct objective
foundation
out loud if you can answer it
october is two months before december
that's correct
um
but it's odd that
they were going to release me from my
role as captain jack sparrow but yet
kept me on every ride across the world
in the pirates the caribbean rides
i'm in the los angeles or the hollywood
one or whatever it is
three or four times
um
shanghai i mean all over the world so
they didn't remove
my character from the rides they didn't
stop selling merchandise of captain jack
sparrow they didn't stop selling dolls
of captain jack sparrow he didn't stop
selling anything
they just
didn't
want there to be something
trailing behind me that they'd find and
you aren't aware you said pirate six in
in your view is dangling you're you're
not aware of if or when pirate six will
be made correct
and the fact is mr depp if disney came
to you with 300 million dollars and a
million alpacas
nothing on this earth would get you to
go back and work with disney on a
pirates of the caribbean film that is
true mister rottenborn
and you couldn't identify
a single movie
that you did between the divorce and the
op-ed
in response to miss meyer's questions
just now you said there was a small tour
of your band between that but you
couldn't identify a single movie that
you did
in the year or two prior to the op-ed
correct
i
i i have to tell you that
when i'm working on a film i do my work
and when i'm wrapped
on that film i've done my work and i
move on to the next so i i haven't seen
the majority of my films i've seen a few
only if i had to
but so i i it doesn't come
right away to my head that's
films are not the first thing that i
think about
[Music]
you